[Musique]
le président de la fédération des zones
d'activité économique de la martinique
également président de la commission
aménagement du territoire à la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie avec nos
bonjour jean pierre bideau des sommes
aujourd'hui auto enfin enfin jean pierre
bideau des cham en fait la grève à la
cft est finie les bus vont pouvoir
rouler de nouveau l'activité économique
va pouvoir reprendre il est peut-être un
peu trop tôt pour tirer un bilan
définitif de cette grève notamment pour
cette zone de la jambe est irrigué la
première à part la cft oui trop tôt mais
la première question qu'on veut se poser
c'est pourquoi il faut pas trois
semaines trois semaines de blocage
complet pour régler des problèmes de
transferts de salariés d'une des
titulaires de marché à un autre alors
que ce sont des dispositions d'ordre
public
c'est ça la dram de la martinique c'est
que tout prend trop de temps
on manque le dg neri n'ont en manque de
volonté d'efficacité on manque de
réalité de pragmatisme
on part dans des théories très très
grande ont fait des grandes études on
parle beaucoup mais sur le terrain les
choses ne vont pas assez vite et la
martinique s'endort et se meurt il ya
3500 jeunes qui partent chaque année de
notre département
il suffirait comme ça d'être un petit
peu plus audacieux dans vide
les prises de décisions pour que les
choses aillent de façon plus efficace
mais oui parce que le système de
développement le système de vie
économique c'est un système moteur qui
se nourrit de lui même donc une volonté
pragmatique de mettre en choses dans de
mettre en place des choses rapidement
vont générer une spirale positive de
construction de quelque chose qu'ils
vont faire revenir les jeunes qui vont
créer des activités etc etc
vous êtes le président on l'a dit de la
fédération des zones d'activités
économiques ce genre de conflit comme on
l'a connu pendant trois semaines avec la
cft eu
est ce qu'il ya une action de
sensibilisation à mener auprès de tous
les acteurs du secteur l'organisation
politique l'entreprise les chauffeurs
mais tout le monde le sel on s'enferme
dans des problématiques et d'un des deux
des postures politiques alors que la
population paye toutes ces semaines de
grève des commerçants de fort de france
ont été asphyxiées pas cette grève parce
que les gens qui prennent les transports
en commun sur la cft eu ce sont les
clients du centre bourg de fort de
france
et même en abords des zones d'activités
sans aucun transport puisque le tcsp ne
circule pas tout tout de suite
ces zones qui deviennent de plus en plus
des zones des espaces commerciaux et non
plus des zones industrielles ont besoin
de l'approvisionnement de leurs
activités par de la circulation et du
transport certes cette fois-ci pillage
le tcsp le tcsp ce fameux tcsp
est ce qu'on doit vous personnellement
un chapiteau des chaumes
est ce qu'on doit vous classez
personnellement dans une catégorie ce
qui en rient ou ceux qui en pleurs j'en
pleure je pleure parce que c'est plus de
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
d'investissements
c'est une projection qu'on espérait du
transport de la martinique dans un
espace futur qui est bloquée figé pas
encore des postures politiques
cette espèce et ssp il se trouve qu'en
tout début de mois vous avez écrit au
président du conseil exécutif et vous
avez fait paraître dans la presse
également une lettre décrivant selon
vous des inepties dans le tracé dans le
fonctionnement prévu du tcsp
l'organisation du transport c'est une
ineptie pour ce que vous en savez déjà
non c'est pas l'organisation du
transport qui est une ineptie
c'est la manière dont ont été gérés
techniquement les interfaces entre les
sorties des zones d'activité et toutes
mes ceglia mancelle de l'argent bêtes ou
des systèmes de feu compliqué inefficace
bloquent complètement les sorties des
zones d'activités et engorge ces zones
avec des asphyxies et on voit très bien
que c'est vraiment un mauvais réglage ou
du des fautes d'ingénierie parce que
lorsqu'on a remis la semaine dernière
les feux clignotants gens très gentils
voulait pas dire de la compétence je ne
juge pas des gens que je ne connais pas
moi je juge les choses sur des résultats
quand les résultats sont catastrophiques
la zone n'est pas d'aujourd'hui qu'on
tire cette sonnette d'alarmé en six
actes sommes en six mois et la troisième
fois que j'écris hauts responsables en
charge de ces de ces problématiques et
j'ai jamais reçu de réponse
pour toute réponse la dernière fois
parce que nous avons publié le dernier
courrier les lécher les les feux sont
repassés à l' orange et ça fait six mois
qu'on le demande on dit en attendant de
trouver des solutions
on a proposé des solutions techniques
pour réaménager le carrefour de la
jambette on ne nous a même pas reçu pour
nous demander notre avis alors en tant
que fédération des zones économiques
qu'avez vous à dire concernant ce tcsp
concernant la circulation au sein de
deux saisons d'économies déjà la
première question que tout le monde se
pose en admettant que ce tcsp roule un
jour pour l'admettant les têtes de ponts
de cé tête de pont aux entrées aux
abords des zones
comment un usager fera pour aller dans
une entreprise où elle pourrait
travailler à l'intérieur des terres
c'est une très bonne question avant le
tcsp c'était déjà un problème le fait
que ces zones soient ce soit en 30 ans
devenu passé de zones industrielles en
zone d'activité économique
et c'est pour ça que nous n'utilisons
plus le mot zone industrielle parce que
ce sont des hommes qui deviennent de
plus en plus des zones de vie des zones
de commerce
le président des crèches l'intérieur
premier l'entreprise aujourd'hui il ya
plus de 350 entreprises sales et les
zones d'activités de la cacem que qui
vont devenu lamenté un fort de france il
ya plus de 350 entreprises
ça représente à peu près trois mille
cinq cents usagers
si on considère qu'aujourd'hui un usager
un contre trois clients dans la journée
ça fait dix mille personnes qui rentrent
et qui sont dans ces zones d'activités
dix mille personnes monsieur breton est
à ce jour là dix mille salariés à ce
jour dix mille visas compteur économique
privée de la martinique qui nourrissent
de leur travail
la plus la valeur ajoutée qui criait
dans ce département
ça demande un peu de respect ça demande
pas un peu de considération dans
l'efficacité quotidienne ça fait dix ans
qu'on travaille sur une voie interdite
vous avez magasin économique
nous avons mal à nous en économique
c'est à régulièrement la jambe est en ce
moment parce que c'est c'est dramatique
parce que quand le tcsp va rouler et je
suis comme vous c'est un investissement
que je souhaite qu'ils fonctionnent
ouais mais après ça que faudra fini
faire nous avons des idées nous avons
des projets on a commencé à tracer des
années que vous réunissez les rues
les années que vous mettez tout sur la
table et ça fait des années que rien
n'avance
par exemple le désengagement de saison
industrielle en relais de danger
survient dans ses rangs quand même pas
loin exactement ce sont des zones avec
des risques technologiques que nous
devons prendre change et c'est très
important que cette prise en charge soit
fait en cohésion avec les acteurs sur le
terrain saison économique l aile de ses
rentes
c'est à dire sur cette voie interne ça
fait dix ans qu'on n'a pas on avait
avant en partenariat avec la chambre de
commerce déposé un dossier de pré étude
pragmatique et pratique pour lancer les
travaux avec des partenariats
public-privé avec les zones d'activités
lorsque la gouvernance de la région qui
est devenu collectivités territoriales a
changé ce dossier a été déchiré et on a
dit on va refaire la même chose
pourquoi ne pas prendre le même dossier
et continuent à le faire avancer plus
efficacement et plus rapidement
non on repart à zéro et ce terrain là il
me tarde de caseros tuer nos matches au
dossier et sa narration jours
n'empêche que vous continuez à dire jean
pierre bideau des chaumes que ces zones
économiques peuvent être véritable
poumon pour l'activité économique de
l'île bien sûr parce qu'on risque de
recettes de 6 des tournées c'est
compliqué d'y aller mais on va aller où
comment on va faire pour nourrir nos
populations comment on va faire pour lui
redonner de l'emploi vous savez les
commerces
c'est ce qui se développe à ces dix
commerçants on va commander sur depuis
son pupitre ethernet et puis lee
commerce dans une île comme la note
c'est quelque chose qui est tangible
mais qui doit être poursuivi par
l'action du dernier kilomètre
quelle que soit la personne qui le fait
lorsque vous allez acheter quelque chose
de matériel parce que on se nourrit pas
dit combien ça on ne se vêtit paddy
commerce
ce sont des choses qui physiquement
doivent arriver à destination des
consommateurs rien à l'amour à donner
elles vont passer par ces zones
d'activités vous aviez quelque chose de
toute façon les commerces des bureaux
électronique avec des réseaux nous
rêvons d'avoir une autonomie de fibre
optique qui travaillent à ce qu'ils
puissent grande la qualité de l'internet
opérationnel
à l'intérieur de ces zones d'activités
donc quelles que soient les gens et les
personnes qui vont travailler dans les
zones
il y aura du monde dans ses zones
d'activité il faut les moderniser il
faut organiser la circulation
nous rêvons de mettre un bus électrique
traverse toutes ces zones pour répondre
à la question de goût mais posez tout à
l'heure avec l'entreprise voilà avec les
entreprises et les entreprises sont
prêtes à apporter leur contribution
il faut qu'on travaille merci d'avoir
écrit ce matin avec nom jean pierre
bideau et charmant rappelle que cette
prise de ma fédération des zones
d'activité économique de la martinique
bonne journée
[Musique]